good morning this is
sticky what's what's sticky my spoon
right here let me see sticky like what
the what the get a different
one put this in the
sink maybe maybe I have don't let it
drip on the floor put your hand up put
your hand underneath
it well it's 6:00 in the morning and
loves to wake up at 6:00 in the
morning and that's all I got you wanted
cereal and usually Monday through Friday
we eat a really nutritious breakfast so
he gets this little play around
breakfast oh who do you think that is my
papa yeah Papa's in California right now
um and he always calls us in the morning
and say good morning so let me talk to
my hubby and then I'll be right back
let's
see is it oh
yeah so I take it back T never lets me
talk to Papa
look they're in my
room T is in my room with
Papa and he took the phone cuz he wanted
to fart on camera so Dad can see
him T what are you
doing oh well come back eat your
[Music]
food
ta oh sorry what is that what blue thing
oh was a blanket oh my God was that
boy that's my
bushy no I mean this
bushy he's so
cute I'm sure Papa wanted to talk to me
too
she T the
dog okay so I have to show you my mom
fit cuz I just don't have time to get
ready the rest of the day about to take
T of practice this is what I decided to
wear here I'll show you over here in my
dirty ass
office yeah keeping it baggy keeping it
hot cuz I know I'm going to get hot
today jeez ready to go let's go now it's
ta's basketball time check it out
like is an orange right
[Applause]
[Music]
there
[Applause]
back
we are all done with ta's basketball
game I didn't want to show too much just
for the privacy of other kids I guess
but now we are getting a k
look so
cool you like it
huh we got the oh now it's wiping it off
taking a shower like on a person take a
shower on the person and like a
dog so it's a shower the car got it yeah
it's a look at the
camera oh yeah it's getting
plastered dude I love how much how many
gas station and car
wash things they have like this um like
most most I want to see like at least a
handful of them that that are out in the
city we live in in Summerland have the
joint um car wash with gas when I gas up
they're like do you want a car I'm like
hell yeah I do and then I I come in here
and like 5 minutes later my car looks
better than it did when I was empty on a
tank of with no gas what am I saying all
right I think I'm just panicking cuz now
it's telling me to almost
go
both wa wa wait wait wait wait wait
wait
go don't oh my God has it been onstop we
just got out of Target we ran in there
we were there for 5 minutes I just
picked up this toy the little boy's name
is Leo so I got Leo cuz we don't know
what he likes right so we got him Ninja
Turtles which
one Leonardo yeah we got Leonardo for
Leo got all of this just set it up in
the car now we are outside of ta's
haircut appointment so he can get his
haircut and we got 2 minutes to spare
woo and then after this we got to go
home let the dogs out shower get ready
I'm done um uh and then what are you
doing back there and then uh and then we
party and then we come home and then and
then and then we just veg out and and
then we then we pose okay we POS so at
his bar have like little games for kids
to play like game consoles and we don't
have that for T at home so he loves
being here for that reason I think it's
such a genius
idea they have stations like this when
the kids are waiting but then for
ta and he talks so much I think
he's playing Mario
Kart look at
him this guy this guy needs a gaming
channel get him
[Music]
my handsome monkey man let me see that
hair let me see that hair let me see
that hair hair hair
ha did you like my
[Music]
mix oh Bo you look good my little K-pop
Star okay let's go change so you could
go to your birthday party for your
friend's birthday party okay now I swear
it's just been crazy upd cuz this is how
life has been today Tao went home he
took a shower we took care of all that
stuff that was in his hair um and then
he got all the little hairs off of his
back cuz those are so itchy huh uh now
we got his friends present and we are at
where's the well we're at Sun Coast it's
a casino right on the more local side of
town but I like to volly Village and
stuff and they reserved uh like the
bowling lanes for about 2 hours so Tech
is going to play with his friends right
now H
dude and I'm going to meet sorts of
parents not the best thing for an
introvert like myself wish me luck I'll
help you in a bit
okay
go hey hey get it ta get it ta get it
ta you like this
[Music]
song
[Applause]
okay we got to go up it says
bowling yep let's
[Applause]
go hey cutie with a cool haircut hey hey
hey hey hey too much booty too much
booty too much too
much
disgusting that booty has all kinds of
poo poo in
it I WIP it you wiped it
here we are bowling center okay let's go
look for your
friend you're still playing you're still
playing 16 tickets so we haven't bowled
yet cuz we found the arcade and taica
and his friends wanted to play in the
arcade
right no that's it you don't get tickets
it just puts it on the
card what what game do you want to play
next what is this I want to this yeah
let's try it what is that
okay here swipe it here here here look
look look oh you put it in there and
then you hope the coin hits
something cool go put it in
here oh that's cool let's see what
happens go look inside look inside look
inside just one at a time where does it
go just one at a
time okay one more time go put it in
let's see where it goes
look
nice I don't know what you're getting I
don't know what this
is I think that's it right what is this
game you got 23
points is this cool these games are
crazy I don't know what any of those
there
is you want to play
that
okay all right ta get ready for college
man you going to play a lot of this when
you go to school let's go oh that's one
way to do
it you want it in the cup in the cup
there you
go oh my God you're crazy boy
dude two balls left two balls left let's
go
a how many points did you get oh you
get 10
points waa look at all that gold look at
all that gold m so I was about to show
you that we were um going to go swimming
and then this guy decides to pull down
his pants PE to go pee don't do that
anymore
please so I've been warming up the whole
pool because now we're entering fall and
um it's starting to get a lot colder
here at night um so the pool is about
like in the
60s I wonder why it's spilling huh uh
anyway so um because it's been in the
60s it does get a little bit colder for
ta he is taking God why is it getting
colder what do you mean it's got colder
I thought you said it was
great I don't think it got colder I
think you just it just changed for
you yeah go show the people what you got
show show them what's your favorite
stroke I am not doing it without I'm
doing them with warm or not cold oh boys
nope
not nope St
doing all right uh so he's been learning
how to swim he did say that the pool was
warm and it felt great and then as I'm
talking to you then he says what the
heck I changed so yeah he's not swimming
anymore I ain't warming up this pool
anymore his lessons are now officially
over just because um it's just getting
pulled up what is your deal this is
you're confused show the people what you
can
do OD it is odd every want to get
out show the people what you can
do not doing it okay we're giving up
here warm up the hot tub I am warming up
the hot
tub all right well never mind I was
going to show you his skills he knows
how to do so he started maybe 3 weeks
ago doesn't know didn't know how to swim
at all got him private lessons with this
really awesome coach that was referred
to me by another mama um good friend of
mine
now and um yeah she killed it within
three weeks he's just floating he knows
how to like float on his back he knows
how to properly breathe he was learning
how to do butterfly freest stroke
backstroke what else did you learn
butterfly butterfly yeah that was it
there was four of them but don't do that
with your goggles dolphin dolphin kick
right which is the whole
butterfly okay it's been a day man um
but I'm so happy and grateful to be home
here of all places It Feels So Serene
out here I love it I wouldn't change my
backyard or my location for the world I
love it here so much I have found home
it feels so peaceful look at that
mountain range over there like come on
the sun's about to set we're just having
a grand old time feels good in
there
big
Bozo how a lot
warmer W warmer than that okay well I'll
join
you okay I'm coming I'm coming yeah so
um yeah we're just going to relax a
little
[Music]
bit in the pool so we are having dinner
outside I ordered some um tacos from
this place called beaches tacos and
these dogs keep getting closer and
closer but yeah I got some flas a
burrito I got like the safe stuff you
know what I'm saying get out of here go
Sho sh sh sho Sho Sho
sh sh
sho hey okay we're going to eat sweaty
cheek so Papa just finished filming just
kiding
newsic and he always calls us you know
himy look look is Theo Joe you see Theo
Joe behind me oh Theo Joe's in the Vlog
too
did you like your did you like your
shirt yes thank you very much I wore it
for the whole time you wor for like 10
10 videos amazing so it's just goingon
to be out there
think nice
Papa yeah do you know a shout out from
Don I I got Papa I mean I got Joe a
shirt that says sounds gay dot dot dot
I'm in I'm like no one else could wear
this shirt except for Joe
look how C this is and and I even
[Music]
candy and that's and we just did a
grocery room realized I didn't have milk
and T loves milk when he goes to sleep
and I'm like what milk is so nasty but
here we are getting milk got and cookies
and
chips
to to go bowling it was like super fun
it was super fun where was it I forgot
the name was it a casino Sun Coast Sun
Coast by toi Village Sun Coast yeah yeah
that's pretty cool and better I put your
hands about
soldiers hey can I speak to Papa now he
looks he has a gun okay I'm going to
speak to Papa now thank
you man I didn't mean for this day to be
so eventful but it was eventful
trust me it's never this intent it's
usually me sitting in front of the
computer and doing a bunch of work and
that's literally my day uh especially on
the weekdays not so much on the weekends
but yes definitely on the weekdays it's
like that so this was very very taxi cuz
I was like I felt like I was driving all
over the city today
but it was worth it cuz I got you a
little bone you're eating your little
bone and you got your little toys and
you could stop chewing up my rug cuz
look our little guy did that just son of
a but it's
okay I was going to get a bigger carpet
anyway I'd love this carpet but I just
wished it was
like I don't know way bigger it's this
really cool
funky rug with really cool patterns but
it's okay time for a new one I'm not
mad you're still a
bastard cuz you still ate my look at
this look at this okay anyway let's end
it on a good note with my perfect little
princess Mia hey Mia Mia I love you I
love you perfect girl I love you perfect
girl I don't do that for you no I do
that for this guy okay anyway going to
shut down this guy's really quiet monkey
man
oh okay time for bed monkey
butt cheese touch tag you okay I'm going
to tag you cheese touch all right guys
thank you so much for watching see you
next time I'm going to knock the
out